subaru share the love event made its
comeback this year giving back to local
organizations that do
so much for our community i was able to
help with the big reveal with the big
czech reveal so take a look at this
[Music]
it is time to share the love once again
with findlay automotive group and subaru
of las vegas we have tyler quarter
here at findlay automotive group and now
you guys are no stranger to sharing the
love right
no this uh the subaru share the love
event fits
uh in perfectly with our findlay cares
program is supporting the local
community and local non-profits
today we have the children's discovery
museum and red rock search and rescue
and we're excited they both do great
things in the community so we're happy
to support them
awesome okay now i want to talk to
burton of subaru of las vegas because
this is your promise to share the love
right what does that mean for you guys
well you know this is our 13th year and
it is something that
really warms our hearts every year we
get to do this
the middle of november to the first part
of january and a total of three hundred
dollars for every car that was purchased
or leased
was given to a choice of a number of
charities and the customer
got to make that choice so for the
discovery children's museum are you
ready you look very excited
we are we are gifting you twenty four
thousand six hundred
and forty eight dollars
[Applause]
is incredible oh look at the confetti
how is this going to impact the museum
this is such a huge impact for us we're
so grateful to subaru for their
partnership burton
and tyler for just engaging us in this
process and all the buyers the car
buyers that have made this gift so
significant
so this funding will help us with our
steam education program
in museum and also with our outreach
programs all right so for our next
recipient introduce us okay
so we're supporting red rock search and
rescue we've supported them for a number
of years through the subaru share the
love
event and they do a great job in our
community helping us find missing loved
ones
and so it's a wonderful cause to support
they're just a great organization
whether they're up in the mountains lee
canyon or red rock or they're in the
city looking for
maybe an alzheimer patient that's
wandered off we just want to uh to help
these first responders and these people
that volunteer their time to help our
community and
this is such a joy okay are you ready
for this donald
all right you are being rewarded thirty
five thousand
two hundred and thirty one dollars
congratulations
donald what does this mean to you oh
this means a lot red rock search and
rescue operates on 100
donations and subaru and finley
automotive group have been our key
supporter for many many years and we
really appreciate what they do for us
these funds all go directly to locate
missing hikers
missing kids alzheimer's kids with
autism and also our first aid and
community training we offer to the
public so
this is a really big boost for us and we
really appreciate it to our 2020
share the love event recipients the red
rock search and rescue
and the discovery children's museum and
all of our community
that came out and purchased subarus
during that period
we toast you this year
cheers to them we want to thank findlay
automotive group for being one of our
community pride partners